michel foucault was a French 20th
century philosopher and historian who
spent his career forensic ly criticizing
the power of the modern bourgeois
capitalist state including its police
Lords prisons doctors and psychiatrists
his goal was to work out nothing less
than how power worked and then to change
it in the direction of a Marxist
anarchist utopia though he spent most of
his life in libraries and seminar rooms
he was a committed ly revolutionary
figure he met with enormous popularity
in elite Parisian intellectual circles
jean-paul Satre admired him deeply and
he still maintains a wide following
among young people studying at
university in the prosperous corners of
the world
his background which he was extremely
reluctant ever to talk about and try to
prevent journalists from investigating
at all costs was very privileged both
his parents were inordinately rich
coming from a long line of successful
surgeons in poitiers in west central
france his father dr. paul Foucault came
to represent all that Michel would hate
about bourgeois France Michele had a
standard upper-class education
he went to elite Jesuit institutions was
an altar boy and his parents hoped he
would become a doctor but Michel wasn't
quite like other boys he started
self-harming and thinking constantly of
suicide at university he decorated his
bedroom with images of torture by Goya
when he was 22 he tried to commit
suicide and was forced by his father
against his will to see Frances most
famous psychiatrist John delay at the
epital santan in Paris the doctor wisely
diagnosed that a lot of Michels distress
came from having to keep his
homosexuality and in particular his
interest in extreme sadomasochism away
from censorious society gradually
Foucault entered the underground gay
scene in France fell in love with a drug
dealer and then took up with a
transvestite for long periods in his
twenties he went to live abroad in
Sweden Poland and Germany where he felt
his sexuality would be less constrained
all the while Foucault was progressing
up the French academic ladder the
seismic event of his intellectual life
came in the summer of 1953 when who
was 27 and on holiday with a lover in
Italy there he came across Nietzsche's
book untimely meditations which contains
an essay called
on the uses and abuses of history for
life in the essay nietzsche argued that
academics had poisoned our sense of how
history should be read and taught they
made it seem as if one should read
history in some sort of a disinterested
way in order to learn how it all was in
the past but Nietzsche rejected this
with sarcastic fury there was no point
learning about the past for its own sake
the only reason to read and study
history is to dig out from the past
ideas concepts and examples which can
help us to lead a better life in our own
times this essay liberated Foucault
intellectually as nothing had till then
immediately he changed the direction of
his work and decided to become a
particular kind of philosophical
historian someone who could look back
into the past to help to sort out the
urgent issues of his own time eight
years later he was ready to publish
what's recognized as his first
masterpiece madness and civilization the
standard view is that we now treat
people with mental illness in so much
more of a humane way than we ever did in
the past
after all we put them in hospitals give
them drugs and get them looked after by
people with PhDs but this was exactly
the attitude that Foucault wish to
demolish in madness and civilization in
the book he argued that things way back
in the Renaissance were actually far
better for the mad then they
subsequently became in the Renaissance
the mad were felt to be different rather
than crazy they were thought to possess
a kind of wisdom because they
demonstrated the limits of reason they
were revered in many circles and were
allowed to wander freely but then as
fuko's historical researches showed him
in the mid 17th century a new attitude
was born that relentlessly medicalised
and institutionalized mentally ill
people no longer were they allowed to
live alongside the so-called sane they
were taken away from their families and
locked up in asylums and seen as people
want you try to cure rather than
tolerate for just being different you
can recognize a very similar underlying
philosophy in fucose next great book the
birth of the clinic his target here was
medicine more broadly he systematically
attacked a few
medicine had become more humane with
time he conceded that of course we have
better drugs and treatments now but he
believed that in the 18th century the
professional doctor was born and that he
was a sinister figure who would look at
the patient always with what Foucault
called the medical gaze denoting a
dehumanizing attitude that looked at a
patient just as a set of organs not a
person one was under the medical gaze
merely a malfunctioning kidney or liver
not a person to be considered as a whole
entity next in Foucault server came
discipline and punish here Foucault did
his standard thing on state punishment
again the normal view is that the prison
and punishing systems of the modern
world are so much more humane than they
were in the days when people just used
to be hung in public squares not so
argued Foucault the problem he said is
that power now looks kind but isn't
whereas in the past it clearly wasn't
kind and therefore could encourage open
rebellion and protest Foucault noted
that in the past at an execution a
convict body could become a focus of
sympathy in admiration and the
executioner rather than the convict
could become the locus of shame also
public executions often led to riots in
support of the prisoner but with the
invention of the modern prison system
everything happened in private behind
locked gates one could no longer see and
therefore resist state power that's what
made the modern system of punishment so
barbaric and properly primitive in
Foucault XY's fuko's last work was the
multi-volume history of sexuality the
maneuvers he performed in relation to
sex are again very familiar Foucault
rebelled against a view that were all
now deeply liberated and at ease with
sex he argued that since the 18th
century
we have relentlessly medicalized sex
handing it over to professional sex
researchers and scientists we live in an
age of what Foucault called ciencia sex
you Alice science of sexuality but
Foucault looked back with considerable
nostalgia to the cultures of Rome China
and Japan where he detected the rule of
what he called an arse erotica erotic
art where the whole focus was on how to
increase the pleasure of sex rather than
merely understand and label it once
again modernity was blamed for
pretending
had been progress when there was in fact
just a loss of spontaneity and
imagination Foucault wrote the last
volume of this work while dying of AIDS
that he had contracted in a San
Francisco gay bar he died in 1984 aged
58 fucose lasting contributions to the
way we look at history there are lots of
things in the modern world that we're
constantly being told are fantastic and
were apparently very bad in the past for
example education or the media or our
communication systems Foucault
encourages us to break away from an
optimistic smugness about now and to go
back and see in history
many ways of doing things which will
perhaps superior Foucault wasn't trying
to get us to be nostalgic he wanted us
to pick up some lessons of way back in
order to improve how we live now
academic historians have tended to hate
fucose work they think it inaccurate and
keep pointing out things he hadn't quite
understood in some document or other but
Foucault didn't care for total
historical accuracy history for him was
just a storehouse of good ideas and he
wanted to raid it rather than keep it
pristine and untouched we should use
Foucault as an inspiration to look at
the dominant ideas and institutions of
our times and to question them by
looking at their histories and
evolutions Foucault did something
remarkable he made history
life-enhancing
and philosophically rich again he can be
an inspiring figure for our own projects
you